Scott's with us in Kentucky hey Scott
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show thank
you Jim and for taking my call make this
short suite as best I can so my wife and
I was uh we she lost her job after 10
years this was back in 2015 we had a
three-year-old at home with no child
care she draw unemployment for as long
as she could I could not make our
mortgage payment on the where I mean I
got a good job I worked for the top 2
delivery companies in the world anyway I
couldn't make the mortgage payment on my
own
we had no child care options so I said
well and I've always I don't I'm never
like that neither one of us like it
we've always paid toward principals on
vehicles got out of debt early so we
sold our house moved to the rural
Eastern Kentucky bought a place we made
good money on the house we sold because
we invested every dime we had into it so
we paid we covered that in half
essentially so from that point on she
stayed at home with our son until he got
a school-aged and she started substitute
teaching to give us a little extra money
however we have been leaning on my
father ever since she lost her job I'm
not proud of it never have been proud of
it but it's the only way we could do
what we got to do as far as you know
making ends meet she now currently you
make for the board what do you make
driving for delivery
I make 40 roughly I made 45 the past
year I've got a 401k and living in rural
Kentucky you couldn't make it on 45 no
I'm worried we've gotta do what I'm
sorry why she was I'm kind of don't know
how much exactly she made substitute and
it was very little as monthly anyway we
bought we had 102 thousand dollar home
in in the place when she lost her job we
sold it made we made fifty thousand on
it
bought another place 400 and paid 50
down on it we paid roughly $350 mortgage
payment we had to take out a home equity
loan for heating air condition certain
plants old house I had to have the whole
thing rewired and everything anyway long
story short I make two grand a month no
you don't and two grand a month twenty
four thousand a year I bring home I'm
sorry I bring home two thousand dollars
a month where's the other two thousand
dollars going I make five hundred a week
you make forty five thousand dollars a
year that's four thousand dollars a
month
- taxes is not two grand insurance 401 K
so your father is giving you my own fund
your 401 K no no I know but you're not
taking another my feed your family maybe
my numbers are off obviously yeah
needless to say while story short I can
the cares Act has been invoked on my 401
K I haven't hurt twenty-five thousand
dollars in there I had not contributed
to that since she lost her job she made
more money now did we've never we don't
have boats we don't have toys we have a
budget what is your question well my
question is we have lived paycheck to
paycheck for the past five years I got
that what's your question we are
considering paying off everything we own
with the 401 K care exact thing okay you
don't owe anything you only the only
thing he owes fifty thousand dollars on
your house right well with the heat
there and the things that I have to do
we owe 68 total and everything we own
yeah and you're gonna pay you're gonna
clean your 401 K out you're gonna have
absolutely nothing if I may the taxes no
yes clean it all out yeah you're gonna
have to to forget 68 and then
because you got to pay taxes the cares
Act doesn't waive taxes it waives the
ten percent penalty and you're treating
the symptom the problem is that you
don't have any idea what you make or
where it's going that's not the real
problem is you guys are going to get a
handle on your money it sounds to me
like she's about to go back to teaching
because you guys can't make it and when
you move out to the country to save
money and you sell a hundred thousand
dollar house and you buy a hundred
thousand dollar house
I missed how you saved money on that
Plus you bought a house then that you
had to renovate so you went backwards
when you did this so no I would not cash
out your 401k because you're hiding from
the issue that's financial denial you're
trying to hide from the issue and the
issue is is that you have no idea what
you make no idea where it's going no
idea what's right because the numbers
are giving her just completely screwed
they don't work they don't add up okay
and if you get on a budget with a $350
house payment making forty five thousand
dollars a year don't do your 401k and
feed your family and it's tight it can
be done it's not what I would recommend
but it can be done but it sounds like
she's gonna have to add back to the
income here more than substitute
teaching she needs to go full-time and
I'll be honest you know there's no
reason why he doesn't have a plan to
move up the ladder he said he delivers
for one of the two one of the two
largest delivery companies in the world
that means that that's amazing working
on UPS because they're based in
Louisville that's exactly right
so I I've got good friends at work at
UPS and that's a company that takes
their employees very seriously there's
an opportunity to grow there if he gets
some gumption here and says wait a
second I'm gonna be the best delivery
driver there ever was with the
opportunity to hopefully move up the
ladder there he could make more at that
company unusually low pay yeah but I'm
saying he could move from unusually low
pay for UPS driver yeah it is
that's what I didn't understand either I
think they're in that 60 range is what
I've experienced but my point is he can
move up the ladder there if he applies
himself that's got to be the issue
budgeting and increasing the income
absolutely no reason he should be taken
away with not a shot your 401 K you're
just hiding from the other issues when
you do that and you're getting ready to
give the government one dollar out of
every three you pull out of there that's
what people don't understand Dave you
get the
question all the time you're gonna get
taxed heavily you don't get the money
dollar for dollar not even close and
what's in the account yeah the cares Act
does waive the 10% but that doesn't mean
you need to cash it out and give the
government one dollar out of three yeah
in order to treat this so here's what
you need to do you and your wife need to
go to a Financial Peace University I'm
gonna pay for it for free doesn't cost
you a thing cuz I've been where you are
where I didn't know didn't know what was
going on
and you're gonna have to get a handle on
what's going on you're getting killed by
not knowing where all this money is
going and making these decisions in a
vacuum so hold on I'm gonna have Madison
pick up we're gonna get you signed up
for that we'll help you get your arms
around this please don't catch up your
401k please don't do that please get in
there and figure out what's really going
on and get the real problem solved